hi everyone it's joanna here today's
class is a low impact hit workout
that means we will not be doing any
jumping at all
the workout time will be 45 seconds with
a short 15 seconds break in between
and because the rest is short this
workout will still be as
intense and it will still drive your
heart rate up
so for those of you who have bad knees
or if you're overweight or perhaps
your joints are starting to feel it from
doing too much of high
impact workouts try this workout okay
so let's get ready and let's warm our
body up let's start with a quick warm up
stand in a neutral position give me some
squats
just to warm our lower body up and
to really wake our muscles up okay
it's low impact but it's still going to
be intense
so let's really prep our body
squat down push back up squat
and push up good now let's add a reverse
lunge okay so squat get into a reverse
lunge
back into a squat and back into a
reverse
lunge good remember
body upright back flat
look straight ahead
one more on each side
down left leg back down
right leg back okay now step wide let's
get into a side to side
lunge all right so we want to warm up
our inner thighs
and our outer thigh
again with every movement you want to
make sure that you brace your core
and that your chest is upright with
your back flat so do not ever
hunch forward okay this is not a lunge
back flat and side
to side good keep going
give it two more on each side
that's one more and
slowly come back up all right now
step right at the edge of your mat let's
warm up
our upper body so slowly inch forward
get into a plank position from here
i want you to push your butt back and
fold your upper body okay so we will
also be doing this workout later on
in the second circuit so just push your
butt back
and get into a plank position
brace your core
and one more and now back into a plank
position
let's drive your left leg forward open
up
back down into a plank right leg
good feel the stretch on your hip flexor
keep going back into a plank
step as far forward as you can really
open up your hip flexor
we will be doing lots of squats and lots
of
lunges last one more
up back into a plank and now slowly
push yourself back up all right good
okay the first second is going to be a
lower body circuit okay
the first workout is going to be a squat
with a tip toe okay so squat down
tip toe reach up squat down if you can
tap the floor so i want you to really
go deep and tiptoe okay
reach down and reach up get
on to your toes
good job keep going find your pace
find your rhythm and maintain
that pace really reach up stretch up
push through your heels and tiptoe
down up down
and up all right good job do you feel
your thighs
right next we're going to level it up a
little bit okay
so start on the floor we want to get
from a
nail to a squat pulse all right so
come back up maintain a low position
give me
three squat pulses back down
back up the other side three squat
pulses
again back down and back up so the goal
here
is to maintain a low position
throughout the entire workout so you
should really
feel the burn on your thighs
and your glutes good pulses
three pulses back down so keep
alternating between legs all right
up house good job feel the burn
give me two more pass
last one more up and
house legs on
fire okay next still working
on our lower body inner and outer thighs
as well as glutes okay start on the edge
of your mat
let's get into a slight lunge change
to a curtsy lunge so you have to also
find your balance and
cross over okay step wide cross
step wipe and
cross push through your heels
feel the work on your
glutes okay you should also feel the
stretch
on your inner thighs so let's work on
one
leg at a time push
if you struggle to find your balance
what you can do is tap
cross tap and
back tap and back okay
so choose your option all right for
every circuit
we want to end with a short cardio
blaster but it's still low impact okay
sprawl so what i'm going to do is get
your chest onto the floor okay
so take a quick step back chest down
quick step
up stand up okay down
and back up remember
it's a quick step we're not jumping
but i want it to be a quick step get
your chest down
onto the floor drive your heart rate up
this workout is intense but it's low
impact let's go bring your heart rate up
step back up
and good keep going
back down up
good job one more up
and come back up all right guess what
we are repeating the entire circuit once
more okay
so your heart rate should be high right
now okay
start in a neutral position let's squat
with
a tiptoe okay so let's go reach for the
floor
tiptoe reach up reach really point
and squeeze your calves really squat as
low as you can
and reach up okay so push your butt back
up push your butt back up
remember keep your chest upright if you
can't
reach the floor that's fine what is more
important
is that you're not hunching forward
this is wrong so chest up tap
up reach up
keep going give you three more squats
and reach for down reach
and come back up all right
you know the next drill new to squat
houses
okay let's start low
spread your knees slightly wider find
your base
stay low throughout ready up pulse
two three back down the other leg change
leg
one two three back down
lead with your right leg one two three
back down now lead with your left leg up
if your thighs are absolutely burning
you can take a short break stand up
and join me back in the workout
once you're ready okay remember to
pace your breathing without
good keep going up
that's one more
and oh my gosh all right
now step at the edge of your mat okay
remember to switch side so we're going
to we're going from
a side lunge to a
curtsy lunge cross over maintain
an upright position body facing
forward do not change the position
of your body good
step wide cross
and wide feel the work on
your glutes out step
cross over out and
step keeping your left leg straight
pushing using the power from
your right leg and
glutes cross that's one more
cross and back up okay
my favorite part a short low impact
cardio blaster
sprawl are we ready remember it's a
quick step
it's not a slow step it's a quick step
ready
get your chest onto the floor quick step
touch
up okay good job
come on stay with me and you will get a
short
break right after this
good job chest down do not cheat
chest down tap
good all the way down and push yourself
all the way back up use the strength
from your upper body and your legs as
well to drive you
back up good job down
push up stand tall
and back down
keep it up keep it up and rest
it out okay oh
starting to sweat my heart rate is at
170 bpm right now
take a shot one minute break rest your
lower body
because we want to work on our upper
body
for round two unpredictable
[Music]
right second round the focus will be
on your upper body okay so we will be
working on the mat throughout the entire
circuit
so there will be planks and there will
also be push up
and we will end with a short cardio
blaster again
all low impacts but it will drive your
heart rate up okay
so now let's start in a plank position
the first workout is going to be an up
down plank
all right with a switch climber so step
in just like what we did
in the warm-up down up
two times step in
and in good so again remember
minimal hip rotation okay
if this is too tough what you can do is
step your feet
wider down up raise the core
push using strength from your arms
step in there you go good
down down up up step
in in that's one more
up and come back up
all right next mountain climbers
to a push up okay so two muscle climbers
one push up choose your option either on
your knees
or on your toes so one two
push up okay one two
get onto your knees push up
choose your option either on your knees
or on your toes
what's most important is that you
maintain a
flat back i know push-up is not easy
it's a really challenging upper body
workout but it's a
really good upper body workout
so if you can't do a full push-up get
onto your knees
come back up two onto your knees
down and up and eventually slowly
progress
into a full push-up
one more and back up okay
now we want to lie on our back
the next workout will be focusing on
your back muscles
and also a little bit on your shoulders
okay
so it's going to be a back extension
reach forward and squeeze your shoulder
blades together
up extend reach and squeeze
remember gaze on
to the floor good job
this workout is really good for
your lower back and your trap
muscles as well reach
and lower it down up
reach and squeeze so do not
drop your arms reach and squeeze
feel the burn extend squeeze
down expand up
and slowly come back up okay
a short cardio blaster okay lateral
background
so what i'm going to do is start at the
edge of your mat get
into all fours okay hover your knees
off the floor and slowly crawl
an inch to the side and back
so do not pike your butt this is wrong
stay low
crawl to the side and back
to the side all right this workout
will drive your heart rate up it's going
to be challenging but stay with me
keep your butt down back flat slowly
inch
left and all the way to the right
minimal movement on your hips as well
okay
do not rotate your hips
stay with me you're almost there back
into the center
and drop back down okay
oh my gosh upper body workout is always
a killer
so let's get back into the first workout
up down plank with switch fibers okay
get into a plank position push yourself
up
back down back up now
left leg forward right leg forward
and down and up
[Music]
up really reach as far forward as you
can
and down minimal
hip rotation okay strong arms
strong core down
up down up
oh it's raining in here
switch switch and
drop onto your knees if at all
you need to get into a child's pose
please
do so alright if not stay with me
two months of climbers one push up
are we ready let's go team one two
one push-up
[Music]
and one push-up good again remember
choose your option okay
don't feel that you have to do something
just because other people is doing it if
you need to get
onto your knees feel free to do so i
want you to make sure that your form
is perfect do not sacrifice your form
in order to advance in a workout
all right let's go push up
down up that's one more
down up and
break oh my god what did i say
i promise you it's gonna be an intense
workout
even though it's low impact okay lie
flat
on your body let's get into
a back extension squeeze
extend squeeze okay hold it
for one count squeeze and
back down one step at a time
relax your lower body focus
on your back muscles your stress
and also your red belt squeeze good job
up squeeze back down
up squeeze
down up
paste your breathing
one more and slowly push
yourself back up okay guys oh
it's dripping in here let me know in the
comments below how you're getting on
final workout start at the edge of
your mat let's get into a lateral
bear crawl okay all the way to the end
scroll back
and back remember do not
hike your butt up
and go good job raise your car
push into the ground use the strength
from your shoulders
push good
one step at a time that's how we get
stronger
and that's how we keep going
okay it's not about rushing i'm just
finishing the workout
it's about getting a quality wrap and
quality workout in
all right okay guys good news
that is the end of circuit two
take a short break bring your heart rate
down stretch if you need to
and we have one final second to go
and the focus will be on your
core muscles
[Music]
i hope you're still with me to finish
the third second
the third circuit will be focusing on
your core the deep core muscle okay
and also your lower back remember that
your core consists of your abs your
obliques
as well as your lower back so again we
will be working on our mat
and it will be a plank challenge as well
alright so now let's start in a high
plank position
the first workout is going to be a
spider and cross plank
so reach your knees out to your elbows
and cross okay so reach out
working on your obliques and cross
good reach reach
and cross again i know this is not
an easy workout if at all you feel that
you need a short break again into a
downward dog
push yourself back give your shoulder a
short break
and back into a plank and continue
with the workout okay so you have your
option right there cross
spider and cross
that's one more cross and cross
okay now get into a reverse position
still working on your core okay crab
toe touch you will also need to work a
little bit on your balance
so step slightly back what i want to do
is reach for your toes
and reach okay so push
your body up feel the crunch on your abs
and reach if this is too difficult you
can start
with your shin to begin with
eventually progress and really crunch up
working on your core and push yourself
up good as high as you can do not
drop your butt stay high stay with me
good reach cross
find your balance okay find one focal
point take it slow
do not rush through this workout
all right now let's get back into a
plank
position we've done this exercise in our
warm-up
so it's a plank to beast start in a high
plank
all i want to do is push your butt back
forward
and back into a plank so as you push
your butt back
feel the work on your core crunch
and release get into a high plank okay
you don't have to go too far forward
high plank push your butt back crunch
and good if you are struggling to do
this workout
it might be that your hips are too tight
so what you want to do
is focus on more stretches for your hip
flexor okay
push it back and up now let's speed it
up a little bit
keep going push it back up push it back
up and back and up
all right good job drop onto
your knees okay finer shot cardio
blaster
in and out plank okay just like playing
jacks but
this is without the jump so again
start in a plank position in and out
okay
i want you to speed it up step
in and step out raise your core
do not shift your hips to the left or to
the right
raise your core five more seconds
and we want to change it a little bit
out out in
in out out in in okay
so remember to keep a flat back
good job do not pike your butt too
high up raise your core out out in
in keep pushing
solid plan i know you're feeling the
burn stay with me
and drop back down okay
last final four minutes okay
one final round and we are done so
spider plank to a cross plank okay
so reach your elbows out out
cross over and repeat
working on your oblique muscles
out out in
and again remember you have the option
to push back
into a downward facing dog hold it for
five seconds
if you're feeling the strain on your
upper body
and now back out out
in in okay so you're taking
a short active recovery
but you're still in this workout
together with me that's one more
cross and drop back down
okay oh my god let's get into
a reverse position crap
toe touch all right let's challenge
ourselves
palms facing forward lift your butt off
reach okay remember to bring your heels
closer to your butt in a 90 degree
position if your heels are too far
forward
then you will struggle to balance
yourself up reach remember
wrench crunch
suck the belly in work on your core
and breathe out as you crunch up
okay just like this breathe out
good job few more
last one more and
back down oh my gosh all right
plank to beast okay this time
let's speed it up a little bit this is
not a difficult move
so let's challenge yourself and bring
the speed up
high plank this plank
and beast really push your butt back
fold your knees okay drive your butt
back
feel the crunch on your core it's not
this okay
fold down feel the stretch on your back
muscles as well push
good bring the speed up
good job guys get into a flat back
plank position do not pike your butt
up push back down
push and
good almost there last one more
up and drop okay good news
you have survived the entire workout now
you have one
exercises left to do okay it's going to
be an
in-out plank let's go let's finish
strong
45 seconds out and in okay
one step at a time and we will switch
at the 20 seconds mark
[Music]
remember keep it back flat
i don't want to see any but hiking in
the air
let's go out out okay now
out out in in push into the ground
suck your belly in feel that burn that's
what we want
a workout should be challenging enough
for you
to see results and progress so
let's end this workout strong push
last two more one more and
very well done okay take this time
to just breathe and stretch out
get into each house pose spread your
knees apart
lower your body down and just stretch
okay
you've done a good job you're not
rushing to go anywhere
so let's take this time to just slowly
bring our heart rate back down
and cool our muscles down
all right good and now slowly
push yourself back up okay
all right now let's get into a downward
facing dog again start in a high plank
position
push your butt back into a high mountain
and now i want you to just walk the dog
okay
drive your heels to the floor
and just keep walking the dog feel the
stretch on your back
good and now slowly get into a plank
lower your body down and push yourself
up
into a cobra okay so remember
do not sink your head
push it away from your shoulders and
just look up
okay stretching our arms shoulders
as well as our lower back
[Music]
and now slowly push yourself back
up let's stretch our legs
so drive your left leg forward
okay again drive
your body weight forward and feel the
stretch on your right hip flexor
if you find that your hips are tight
this is a really good stretch to do
so really just push in again no
hunching forward okay raise your core
stand tall
and now just raise your arms up
and just breathe here let's hold it
for 10 seconds
if you want to you can push deeper feel
a deeper stretch
and now slowly drop twist
again maintaining a flat back all right
twist
[Music]
look as far back as you can
and now just straighten your front leg
and
let's just stretch your hamstrings all
right all the squats all those lunges
let's just stretch it out really well
done guys
really well done low impact but we want
to still maintain the intensity for you
to burn fat
and build strength okay now take a step
back
change the other side right leg forward
again push your body weight forward
feel the stretch on your left hip flexor
right here okay
so don't fight against it just relax
release
breathe out when it comes to stretching
it's all about
allowing your body to go as far as it
can
without forcing it or holding your
breath now slowly
reach up and again
if you want to breathe out and go deeper
hold it right there
and now let's twist the opposite side
flat back look as far back as you can
and straighten the front leg stretching
your hamstring out
i have really tight right hamstring okay
so go as low as you can stretch it out
be gentle again just breathe
into the stretch okay your workout
is your cool down is as important as
your workout
and your warm-up so do not miss your
cool down
and now slowly just step back in
okay let's just stay low let's just
breathe in
release breathe in
ah one more time side really low breathe
in
one two three
well done guys very very well done
that was a 30 minute low impact
heat workout no jumping but still as
intense for you to burn
lots of calories and to build lean
muscle mass
if you enjoyed this workout video don't
forget to give it a thumbs up
subscribe to my youtube channel let me
know in the comments below how you felt
and do also check out a lot more workout
videos meal plans
workout plans as well as fitness tips on
my youtube channel
if you haven't yet subscribed then come
on guys hit the subscribe button and i
will see you next time all the best